the Joker and I broke up I wouldn't a
fresh start but it turns out I wasn't
the only daemon Gotham looking for
emancipation
[Music]
hi i'm mary elizabeth winstead i'm
Ellijay Barco I'm Margot Robbie and I'm
jurnee smollett Bell and we are here and
going to interview each other for our
new film birds of prey okay I'll go with
the first question you're the first all
woman or women superhero movie squad how
did that change the experience on set
anyone wanna marry this one I think I
don't know I don't wanna speak for
everybody but for me it was really
refreshing and liberating because it was
like the first time this has ever
happened to me you know I've worked with
women before I've worked with one or two
female directors but you know I've never
worked on something where every position
of power was led by a woman in one way
or another and it was really exciting
and invigorating and just fun like it
there was no there was nothing
threatening about it like oh this woman
is threatened by the other woman because
they're the only women hood side of her
you know like the times when women have
been pitted against each other in that
way it was just like we're all here to
make something great and to support one
another and have a good time and it was
like amazing good do the next question
what did you want to know do the next
question the costumes in this film are
incredible did you have any say in them
and did they affect / enhance your
performance at all
I loved the costumes our costume
designer Aaron is just Erin with the
list the woman in the world and
everything we tried on I was like okay
if this doesn't end up in the movie
please can I do it I wouldn't wear all
the things that Holly wears at once but
I definitely on their own wear it and
how did it affect my performance I mean
I felt like Harley cuz my clothes were
they looked very impractical which is
definitely how Holly does things it's
it's not about practicality it's about
what's shiny and fun and what she wants
to wear but actually like the costume
department would make it so it was
completely practical to fight in like
yes stretchy bits here so I could kick
higher or whatever were they yeah it was
wild that's good what
I had the pink cast and they gave me
they sent me like two or three casts and
I just drew all over them so all of the
stuff on the actual cast is my art and
then we just I said what something very
rude yeah I just sat there for for like
an hour too and they just made like 15
of them so I do that that was that was
that was definitely fun and that like it
was my did you camera oh good and we
know those first shoes you had kept
giving you blisters though I do remember
that because L is been growing at an
alarming rate this entire fit everyone
pees like three inches taller in a week
and you're like we had to we had to have
multiple fittings because I jumped
different sizes like every month or so
and then we went back to do reshoots and
your shorts that were like normally down
your leash or Daisy do we need to get
okay what would you describe as
fantabulous I'm going with that
yeah thanks Nikki and the fact that you
and Mary know really with Nikki cut my
hair out I looked at the mirror I was
like I I just hope it was like a
positive knowledge
because she cut me she cut my hair and I
wasn't in the mirrors I didn't know what
she was doing
literally I said I trust you Nikki and
give me whatever you want and I walked
it I was like I look like Mary this is
good we all just pulled up with America
all right good
okay I'll go is there a side of yourself
that you tapped into in order to play
your character and where did you draw
that inspiration from I think with Holly
it's always fun like to find your inner
child and because she she has she's not
childish maybe at times but she's very
childlike with her excitement and
fascination with fun things and that's
always fun and I could eat like a lot of
junk food in my teeth
at this point so much sugar consumed on
this so many so many egg sandwiches I
think so many eggs egg sandwiches I am
allergic to chicken egg white she which
is weird in its own but they give me
migraines there's a protein and a
chicken egg whites that can give people
migraines and I get it and we wrote into
the prop people like Andy was like why
did you write it and you guys write it
into the script that you're eating egg
sandwiches haqqani eggs I was like I
know it didn't economy at the time yeah
they had to make them with duck eggs
it was very so sorry I'm not difficult
on any anything else when they make you
food on in scenes and stuff they like a
lot of people don't eat certain things
or don't want sugar or whatever so they
have to make it all tricked out but I
was like no way absolutely everything
except eggs which I eat in a lot of
things oh he was funny you take her I
texted you and I was saying you know the
pups told me if we were eating duck eggs
even you were like yeah it's just just a
migraine thing I was like wow I ate like
50 decades I feel more sophisticated
did you perform any of your own stunts
if so what was the most challenging one
I saw you guys do all your own stunts
yeah yeah we trained pretty long to ax
kick man sorry yeah that act K innocent
is I know but yeah I think the kicks in
general because it made me have to
become crazy flexible Wow
tearing the muscle it was this weird
thing of like every day they were
ripping my muscles and then yet I had to
like stay flexible and lean and it was
and strong and it was it was painful do
you remember how Shane used to stretch
oh yeah do those stretches on the wall
oh yeah it was brutal I felt for you
because I mean because you really it was
all legs for you so yeah like stretching
and then he would tell me ten more
seconds and it felt like a minute
yeah it was probably going good it looks
good what was your most challenging
stunt do you think you got to do that
nice liderman we slide I find them hard
yeah that was that was hard but I mean
for me honestly it was fun uh there were
everything was so fun I mean the care
something that was the most fun I got
the carousel I'm sorry yeah good for you
you guys were like dude there's nothing
fun about it you know it was just
exhausting and and long cuz it was just
so you know we had a lot of big long
runners which is what was sort of
unusual about this film and the action
scenes is that it required perfection
from every single person involved which
is such a ballet it was yeah really big
dance wearing
not to mention all the stunt performers
like flying with being and like taxing
themselves time up to time off the time
Oh God what was your most difficult well
the carousel was was tough you know that
was that was challenging for all of us I
think for me I have a sequence a fight
sequence on all these bouncing tongues
like such a full body workout because I
would have to be like sliding under it
with sort of lifting myself up with my
abs and then pushing myself onto it with
my arms and then jumping up with my legs
and then just like such a workout have a
new craze for you la Margot as a
producer on this film and getting to
started getting to starting on your own
I can't read what did you fight to
include into this film Argo what did I
fight to include I feel like I fought to
include so many things oh gosh I mean
fighting for an hour rating was probably
the biggest and first fight fighting to
get everyone wasn't so I mean it was a
bit of it took a bit of convincing to
say like we can put a group of women on
screen in an action film and it will
work that was probably the first fight
an r-rated that was a that was another
fight and then yeah lots of little
things along the way he fights
everything you fight for a location you
love you fight well kind of like some
sort of artistic choice that the
creative group of fighting for but it
might not make sense on a financial side
and you go to pick your battles because
you go to allocate funds in the right
places but ultimately we I'd say overall
got everything we want and the thing is
when you don't have enough money for
something you then go back to the
drawing board and everyone comes up with
a really creative way to do it for less
money and then
ends up being cooler than what you
thought of initially anyway so it the
parameters are sometimes a blessing in
disguise what's your earliest memory of
going to the movies
Georgia at the jungle yeah people always
have a cool answer like Oh 2001 a Space
Odyssey and I'm like the one I can
remind remember going to see home alone
I think that's a great first movie yeah
like my son I remember drinking like a
chunk like one of those like so does
that was like this big the whole thing I
can't remember if it was Lion King or
Malcolm X which says a lot about my
mother I can't remember which one was
first it probably both good answers both
were very I was very young and both made
a massive impact for very different yes
what about you honestly I don't remember
what movie I just remember the
experience in itself because I would
always go with my grandma in Downey and
we would always sit in the very front of
the theater so I just remember neck
cramps the whole time of like watching
like whatever it was like minions or
something and like loved the smell of
garnet like the popcorn so I used to go
and sit at the cinema when I couldn't
get a ticket or go see a movie I just
sit and watch like the trailers play on
the big screen that plays outside and
just sit there and smell popcorn do that
like an hour and a half when you go to
the movies now do you get snacks
yeah or no like have you ever gone to
the movie and been like I'm good I don't
I went to a movie last night and I snuck
in wine and wine and buggering is a
beautiful combination burger rings that
something from Australia but they're my
favorite thing in the whole world goes
well with the Chardonnay apparently so
one time my cousins and I one of my
cousins he wanted sushi so we so so we
went to sushi and he said God were late
let me just get it all in a bent Puck's
so we were like passed down another hand
roll like eating sushi watching got you
caught it smells though like you gotta
pick a food I've never done that so I
mean it was my mom one time brought rice
and beans and chickens fed us all it was
great my mom he's so like we'd always if
we went as a family ever we did a few
times but she was like we can't buy call
come there it's outrageously expensive
we'll make it at home and we'd bring a
Tupperware container in her handbag of
the popcorn and would complain cinema
you